und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
letzten Monat hatte Bundesfinanzminister
Christian Lindner ja sein Entwurf für
den nächsten Bundeshaushalt vorgestellt
nun geht es an die Details in den
bekanntlich der Teufel steckt bzw der
größte Konfliktstoff nämlich die Frage
wie das Ganze finanziert wird der
Haushalt ja gerne auch mit etwas Pathos
als das schicksalsbuch der Nationen
bezeichnet fast auf jeden Fall in Zahlen
wo eine Regierung ihre Prioritäten setzt
und welche Spielräume sie angesichts der
Wirtschaftslage hat derzeit keine großen
berichtet unser Korrespondent Frank
Buchwald den der finanzierungsentwurf
bereits vorliegt
monatelang haben sie gerechnet im
Finanzministerium nun ist klar im
Haushalt für 2024 regiert der Rotstift
alle Ministerien müssen sparen damit die
Schuldenbremse greifen falsch kritisiert
die linke Opposition wir haben in
Deutschland kein ausgabeproblem wir
haben ein Einnahme Problem und wir sind
eines der wenigen Länder die keine
Vermögenssteuer haben bzw
Erbschaftssteuer wo fette Erben bzw
fette Erbschaften mit den ganzen
mickrigen Steuersatz versehen sind und
das geht überhaupt nicht in einen
solchen Zeiten Kritik entzündet sich vor
allem an drei Themen Rentenversicherung
CO2-Preis und Elterngeld so sollen etwa
die Zuschüsse zur rentenpflege und
Arbeitslosenversicherung geringer
ausfallen bei Gewerkschaften und
Arbeitgebern stößt das auf Unverständnis
in einer Stellungnahme der BDA heißt es
der Aufgaben zu Lasten der
Arbeitslosenversicherung verlagert und
Zuschüsse zur Renten und zur sozialen
Pflegeversicherung kürzt spart nicht
sondern Frucht lediglich eigene Lasten
auf das Konto der beitragsgemeinschaft
um die FDP widerspricht der
Bundeshaushalt wird nach wie vor ein
dreistelligen Milliardenbetrag pro Jahr
der Rentenversicherung zur Verfügung
stellen das heißt hier müssen wir uns
auch ehrlich machen der Bund ist hier
stark in der Verantwortung und ein
Automatismus hinzu
rentenbeitragserhöhungen gibt es nicht
Energie wird die Bürger bald wohl
deutlich mehr kosten fürs Auto aber auch
beim Heizen die bereits von der großen
Koalition beschlossen soll die
CO2-Abgabe um ein Drittel von 30 auf 40
€ pro Tonne klettern das verteuert Gas
und Öl der Spritpreis dürfte wohl um 3
Cent pro Liter steigen schätzte ADAC
großer Aufreger auch die geplanten
Kürzungen beim Elterngeld eine
Entscheidung der Familienministerin sie
muss 500 Millionen Euro einsparen
die zuständige Ministerin Pauls bleibt
bisher bei ihren Kürzungsvorschlägen wir
haben Alternativen vorgelegt und wir
hoffen dass wir Frau sie noch überzeugen
können
am Mittwoch soll das Kabinett über die
Sparvorschläge beraten wie viel von
ihnen am Ende jedoch Wirklichkeit wird
entscheidet im Herbst der Bundestag
eines kann man über den nächsten
US-Wahlkampf jetzt schon sagen er wird
sich zu einem erheblichen Teil in
Gerichtssälen abspielen das liegt
zunächst daran dass Donald Trump in sich
Verfahren verwickelt ist die Vorwürfe
reichen von sexuellen Übergriffen über
Mitnahme geheimer Staatspapiere bis hin
zur gewichtigsten aller Anklagen
Verschwörung zum Betrug gegen die
Vereinigten Staaten Stichwort
Putschversuch man könnte vielleicht
meinen seine Partei wäre gut beraten
einen solchen Kandidaten eher
loszuwerden doch Trumps gegen Strategie
verfängt statt über meine vergehen
lassen uns lieber über den Sohn von Joe
Biden reden wird dessen Fall gibt es
jetzt einen Sonderermittler David sauer
berichtet aus Washington
kommt da auf den US-Präsidenten ein
Problem aus der Familie zu der eigene
Sohn könnte zur Belastung werden im
Wahlkampf alle Vorwürfe gegen
Handarbeiten müssten jetzt durch einen
Sonderermittler transparent aufgeklärt
werden so begründet der Justizminister
seine Entscheidung
die Benennung unterstreicht das
Engagement des Justizministeriums
Unabhängigkeit und Rechenschaftspflicht
zu gewährleisten in einer besonders
sensiblen Angelegenheit
Republikaner hatten diesen Schritt lange
gefordert der wird weiß hat nun diese
Rolle mit weitreichenden Befugnissen es
geht um Steuerhinterziehung und
illegalen Waffen Besitz an Deal zwischen
Hunter beiden Anwälten und der
Staatsanwaltschaft war kürzlich geplatzt
ein Prozess ist jetzt wahrscheinlicher
es könnte also einen Wahlkampf werden
der in Teilen vor Gericht abläuft Donald
Trump muss sich in mehreren Verfahren
verantworten Wahlbeeinflussung der Sturm
aufs Kapitol versteckte Geheimdokumente
da kommt es ihm gerade recht dass sich
das juristische Ungemach in der Familie
beiden ausweitet die Negativschlagzeilen
geben Republikanern die Gelegenheit das
Thema auch im Wahlkampf gegen Joe Biden
zu verwenden sie hoffen dass auch an ihm
etwas hängen bleibt Donald Trump selbst
war es der als Präsidentin jetzigen
sondereinmittler beauftragt hatte gegen
Hand der beiden zu ermitteln dennoch
versuchen manche Republikaner dessen
Unabhängigkeit in Zweifel zu ziehen das
ist zu 100% ein politischer Schachzug
wie kann man jemanden nennen der vor
weniger als zwei Wochen erst versucht
hat ein Wohlfühl-Angebot zu fahren
alle fanatischen trumprechtsaußenleute
schreien jetzt und sagen dass sei nicht
richtig nicht fair nicht gerecht der
ehemalige Präsident versucht dieses
Thema zu benutzen um sein eigenes
Verhalten zu entschuldigen
Fragen dazu beantworten nein danke als
Präsident beiden zum Wochenende in
seinen Privathaus abreißt das Thema wird
ihm sicher erhalten bleiben
jeder Journalist weiß es jede
Hilfsorganisation und auch die
Bundeswehr ohne die sogenannten
ortskräfte ist man im Ausland nicht
arbeitsfähig schon gar nicht den
Krisenländern da geht es ja nicht nur
ums Dolmetschen sie helfen Zugang zu
Einheimischen zu bekommen Situationen
einzuschätzen warnen gegebenenfalls auch
vor Gefahren da sollten wir besser nicht
hinfahren mir ist da was zu Ohren
gekommen es sind oft nicht nur
Mitarbeiter sondern Vertrauensperson und
die ortskräfte von Bundeswehr und
Entwicklungshelfern in Afghanistan
hatten auch den deutschen vertraut doch
dann wurden tausende von ihnen einfach
zurückgelassen als vor zwei Jahren das
Chaos im Kabul ausbrach es gab keinen
Schutzkonzept aber jede Menge
bürokratische Hürden daran erinnert ein
der Junge Afghane in Berlin will
unerkannt bleiben sich und seine
Angehörigen nicht in Gefahr bringen er
will uns mit seinem Onkel verbinden
Unterlagen belegen der arbeitet als
ortskraft in Afghanistan für die
deutschen seither lebt er mit seiner
Familie versteckt in Kabul wartet auf
seine Ausreise
wir haben für die Gesellschaft für
internationale Zusammenarbeit gearbeitet
wir haben dafür unsere Leben auf Spiel
gesetzt und jetzt wir ärgern uns über
die deutsche Regierung keine Antwort auf
unsere Fragen niemand kümmert sich um
unsere Probleme
über 40.000 besonders gefährdeten
Afghanen und Afghanen sowie ihren
berechtigten Familienangehörigen hatte
die Bundesregierung eine Aufnahme in
Deutschland in Aussicht gestellt
darunter viele ortskräfte doch nur etwa
11.000 Menschen sind bislang nach
Deutschland eingereist Grund für
selbstkritische Betrachtung auch in
politischen Berlin
das Deutschland stärker als andere
Länder wenn es im Zweifel zwischen
Bürokratie und Humanität geht sich also
auch für die Bürokratie entscheidend und
ist damit Menschen schwer macht und das
ist nicht erfreulich und das gehört zu
den Dingen die aufzuarbeiten haben auf
dem ortskräftekongress in Berlin heute
der Appell deutschland müsse Worst Case
Szenarien auch für andere Krisenregionen
wie Mali den Sudan oder Liga entwerfen
das muss in Friedenszeiten muss man sich
überlegen wie gehen wir in der Krise
auch mit unseren eigenen Angestellten um
und es ist nicht vielleicht sinnvoll die
vielleicht zumindest aus der
Gefahrenzone irgendwie zu unterstützen
dass sie fliehen können es brauche ein
Konzept für den Schutz lokaler
Beschäftigter zumindest das sollte die
Lehrer aus Afghanistan sein
und jetzt geht es bei die erstmal weiter
mit den Nachrichten es gab wieder
russische Luftangriffe in verschiedenen
Regionen der Ukraine nach Angaben von
dort wurden mindestens zwei Menschen
getötet und mehrere verletzt Russland
wiederum hat Angriffe auf die krimbrücke
gemeldet die das russische Festland mit
der besetzten ukrainischen Krim
Halbinsel verbindet mehrere Raketen sein
abgefangen worden die Brücke sei
unbeschädigt
der deutsche Richter Bund hat seine
Kritik an der von
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
geplanten Cannabis Legalisierung
bekräftigt in einer Stellungnahme zum
Referent Entwurf widerspricht der
Richter Bund unter anderem der
Einschätzung dass die Justiz entlastet
werden zudem führe das Gesetz nicht zu
einer Einschränkung des Schwarzmarktes
im Gegenteil sei mit einer Zunahme zu
rechnen und auch dem Ziel den Kinder und
Jugendschutz zu stärken werde der
Entwurf nicht gerecht
bei einem Bootsunglück im Ärmelkanal
sind mindestens sechs Migranten auf dem
Weg nach Großbritannien ums Leben
gekommen 59 Menschen konnten nach
Angaben der französischen
Staatsanwaltschaft von anderen Schiffen
in Sicherheit gebracht werden auch vor
Tunesien gab es ein Boot zu Unglück
mindestens zwei Menschen ertranken 13
konnten dort gerettet werden das
Hilfsschiff Ocean Viking hat in den
letzten zwei Tagen im Mittelmeer bei
mehreren Einsätzen mehr als 600
Migranten gerettet sie sollen in Italien
an Land gebracht werden
auf der Hawaii-Insel Maui hat sich nach
den verheerenden Bränden die Zahl der
Todesopfer auf mindestens 80 erhöht und
es wird befürchtet dass noch mehr Opfer
gefunden werden weil die Rettungskräfte
erst nach und nach in das Innere
zerstörte Gebäude vordringen können
inzwischen ist eine Untersuchung
eingeleitet nachdem es Kritik gab die
Behörden hätten nicht ausreichend vor
der Katastrophe gewarnt
es ist zwar etwas unbehaglich jetzt
Mitte August schon an den Herbst zu
denken aber er wird ja unweigerlich
kommen und mit ihm Grippe erkältungs-
die Erdnuss war schuld Mali hat sich
daran verschluckt danach beginnt eine
Odyssee drei Kliniken kein Personal
keine Ressourcen bei Helikopter landet
sie schließlich hier und Marlies Mutter
hat kaum Worte für das alles war die
Hölle auf Erden würde ich sagen also
die schlimmste Nacht Marlies Geschichte
spiegelte Misere der Kinderkliniken in
Deutschland Pflege Notstand zu wenig
Betten Notfälle die abgelehnt werden
müssen es ist ein tägliches jonglieren
morgen Besprechung im haunerschen
Kinderspital in München die Situation
ist dramatisch weil Kinder Medizin eben
anders funktioniert zeitintensiver ist
und deshalb chronisch defizitär
ist nicht abgebildet dass Kinder eben
viel viel mehr Fürsorge brauchen dass
alle Leistungen die blutnamen enger
brauchen und das wäre auch noch Eltern
mit betreuen
ein stiller Moment auf der
Intensivstation Berührung Zuspruch
Pflegerin Christina versucht sich Zeit
zu nehmen für den schwerkranken jungen
dabei ist die Station gerade wieder
unterbesetzt wie fast immer dann hat man
natürlich die Zeit und die Hände die
sich um die Patienten kümmern können da
muss halt das notwendige gemacht werden
nebenan der nächste Notfall ein Junge
bewusstlos Verdacht auf Hirnblutung ist
eilt keine anästhesie-schwester Andrea
wird aus einer laufenden Operation
abgezogen Löcher stopfen klinikalter
oben meine Kollegen müssen mit
übernehmen wir haben keine Ressourcen
der Mangel an Pflegekräften ist das
größte Problem trotz Gehaltserhöhungen
in den letzten Jahren der Nachwuchs
zögert Nicole Wöhler ist seit 25 Jahren
Kinderkrankenschwester sie liebt ihren
Beruf und wirbt dafür weil er Leben
verändern weil er etwas bewirken kann
trotz aller Widrigkeiten
wir arbeiten ja auch Wochenende der
Schichtdienst alle feiern Weihnachten
Heiligabend zu Hause wir feiern halt
hier mit dem Patienten oder mit den
Eltern was auch total schön ist aber man
muss es halt wirklich mögen mit Geld
allein ist das Problem Pflege Notstand
wohl nicht zu lösen und hier wächst
derweil die Sorge vor Virus und
Grippewellen jetzt haben wir eben dann
den Herbst und die neue Infektionswelle
vor uns und das bedeutet eben dass wir
wieder dramatisch mehr Patienten haben
und diese Patienten kommen einfach in
die Notaufnahme die kommen vom
Rettungsdienst einfach reingefahren egal
ob der Platz haben oder nicht Mali
übrigens hat das Schlimmste überstanden
die Erdnuss ist raus aber von
Krankenhäusern sagt ihre Mutter hat sie
echt genug
und ist die Lottozahlen dieses samstags
sie lauten wie immer ohne Gewähr 19 20
24 33 40 43 Superzahl 3 weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf Lotto Punkt
zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite 556
die Wetteraussichten für morgen bei
einem Wechsel von Sonne und Wolken wird
es vor allem zwischen Main und Donau
schaue und teils kräftige Gewitter geben
die Temperatur steigt auf Werte von 21
bis 31 Grad und die weiteren Aussichten
das mit 21 bis 32 Grad sommerliche warme
Wetter mit Schauern und Gewittern setzt
sich auch in der nächsten Woche fort
das war's mit dem Aktuellen Sportstudio
geht es gleich weiter da ist ja auch
einiges los in der Fußballwelt und um
09:15
[Musik]